gestern war das auch schon indirekt das
duell zwischen armin laschet und markus
söder denn die kanzlerfrage steht noch
immer aus in der union was glaubst du
hat das jetzt für auswirkungen auf genau
diese frage die sich ganz deutschland
stellt ja wie immer im leben lohnt es
sich oder geht eigentlich nur was weiter
wenn man eine ehrliche richtig ehrliche
hatte analyse des eigenen scheiterns
oder des eigenen erfolges macht das
kennt man im sport fußball trainer die
sich nicht eingestehen wollen dass es
sich in der aufstellung getäuscht haben
und daran festhalten machen oft
schlechter erfahrungen konzernlenker die
an einer strategie zu lang festhalten
sind nicht in der lage ihre produkte
besser zu verkaufen das gilt auch für
die politik denn dort gibt es das
personal das sind die damen und herren
die wir gestern alle wieder gesehen
haben bis übrigens auf die wichtigsten
armin laschet er sicher nicht gezeigt
hat gut dann etwas wichtigeres vorher
musste geheim zu angela merkel
also jedenfalls fast geheim denn wir
wissen ja dass er da war
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass dort
war er rauchende köpfe statt rauchende
colts na dann jetzt erstmal eine große
niederlage zu verarbeiten und noch nicht
der modus attacke obwohl der mal so
langsam kommen müsste mit einem
überzeugenden programm
wir können ja mal durchgehen also es ist
glaube ich herrschende meinung dass
weiter so nicht geht
das bedeutet schon mal dass sich frau
merkel am besten ganz raus hält sind sie
steht ja praktisch als ganze person für
weiter so seit unzähligen jahren für
weiter so egal ob die politik gut oder
schlecht aufgegleist war armin laschet
an das problem dass er als die
fortsetzung von angela merkel gilt also
für ein weiter so armin laschet ist das
verkörperte das personifizierte weiter
so und damit genau der falsche mann und
der falsche politikertypus für den
jetzigen moment in der union
und vielleicht hilft es ihm wenn man ihm
zahlen die ja hoffentlich kennt einfach
nochmal vorliegt also erlasse tacheles
ja
nehmen wir mal den korruptionsfall ja da
kann man sagen drei leute die haben sich
halt verfehlt ich habe mir mal den spaß
in anführungszeichen gemacht und hab mal
den korruptions inzidenz wert ist ein
berühmter begriff zurzeit den
korruptions inzidenz wert der union
ausgerechnet also drei von 244
abgeordneten entspricht einem incidents
wert nach der krone formel
von 1229 1229 ist die korruptions
inzidenz der union im parlament da
müssen ja alle alarmglocken angehen bis
zum geht nicht mehr und man muss sagen
hier müssen wir in den lockdown lockdown
heißt hier neue regeln schnell ahndung
der vergehen klare ansprache den
betroffenen sicherstellen dass es in der
fraktion übrigens auch in allen anderen
aber die haben das problem gerade nicht
nicht zu weiteren fällen und infektionen
kommt also einfach mal das eigene die
eigene corona rechnung auf eine
korruptions solche anwenden und schon
weiß man wie es steht und besonders
gefährlich werden ein exponentielles
wachstum jetzt also es gibt ja unter
korruptions forschung ist bekannt dass
da wo ein bisschen korruption ist
meistens mehr korruption ist weil sie
sich tatsächlich exponentiell ausweitet
das will ich jetzt hier nicht
unterstellen weil die fälle schon zum
teil mit aserbaidschan so schuldig sind
dass man jetzt vielleicht keine
systemische sache dann erkennen kann
aber ich sage nochmal die korruptions
inzidenz der union im deutschen
bundestag ist 1229 das lässt ja schon
mal auf wir können uns auch anschauen
was mit den mitgliedern der union ist
also den union union union union
menschen cdu in den letzten zehn jahren
100.000 leute weg jetzt haben sie nur
noch knapp 400.000 mitglieder
das ist problemen geld aber vor allem
probleme in commitment und dann lass uns
auf die umfragen im bund schauen lieber
herr laschet ja vor ein paar wochen noch
40 bäume wir erinnern uns 40 plus ist
eigentlich die gewohnte wir sind groß
logik der union
da waren es noch 40 er träume jetzt
graebert man bei irgendwo um die dreißig
rum mit einer großen 20 euro v also wenn
wir bei der cdu/csu irgendwann mal 29
steht oder 26 oder 24 dann geht sie den
gang der spd in die notaufnahme auf die
intensivstation und irgendwann dann ins
hospiz ins hospiz der volksparteien die
ja das muss man sagen beide großen
volksparteien wieder schaden genommen
haben die eine feiert sich als sieger
ist aber eigentlich auch verlierer in
beiden ländern und hat verloren
die spd und die andere kommt in die
benannten schwierigkeiten also erlassen
es ist
der sekunde einen turnaround zu schaffen
wenn man nicht im abgrund für sinken
wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren